broken abilities have the potential to
completely take you out of the game
at the end of it we often find ourselves
asking how did anyone think putting this
in the game was a good idea some of them
belong to characters that really didn't
need the help while others are just
broken all on their own but all of them
make people ask why did they do this
just before we get into this video make
sure you are subscribed to the score
esports and that way you'll never miss a
video just like this one and with that
let's get into the top 10 broken
abilities
kicking off our list at number 10 it's
the time dota 2 became a 6 on five game
the battle begins
chen's holy persuasion ability usually
lets him make friends in the jungle but
in dota's patch 6.75 he was able to make
a slightly bigger friend
that's right chen's persuasion was
bugged and now worked on roshan not only
that he could do this at level one that
meant roshan could head into lane with
chen and push towers with his team
winning the game pretty fast since
roshan is immune to all damage when he's
not in the pit
daya's ancient is under
this got fixed pretty quickly which is
why it isn't higher up on the list but
for the brief moment chen could take
roche out for a stroll it was an
extremely overpowered ability
taking the number nine spot on our list
are starcraft 2's investors and their
fungal growth ability positioning his
army so he can protect this sport but as
this moves
oh my god buckles on everything
all that's left to the floors of the
tanks and he does
a pickup by marie king but stefano
waiting for the perfect moment and
completely decimates the army look
starcraft is a complicated game but one
thing is always true if you can destroy
a bunch of your opponent's units and
lose nothing in the process that's going
to be a winning strategy during
starcraft 2's first iteration wings of
liberty a dominant zerg strategy
coalesced playing for late game and
building the new investor unit it
actually had a number of good abilities
but the ability we're talking about that
would eventually be nerfed was fungal
growth a four second immobilized to air
or ground units that also dealt damage
and prevented units from getting into a
transport unit or from transforming
genius
yeah he is that's quite true he's going
to have to hit some sort of timing
attack coming up here oh
very nice
and it looks like the phoenix harassment
and defense is over with
so the strategy was pretty simple get
some investors use fungal growth several
times to lock down your enemies grouped
unit and then send in your brood lords
to attack from a safe distance it
basically prevented your opponent from
playing the game and you can see that 70
marines they're slowly getting worn down
he brings in some extra hydras
he's got about 12 hydras and so with 12
hydras he's going up against this army
that once was 70 marines
taking some out but losing some hydras
backs up a little more because he wants
to get that separation from those
medevacs
but uh this strategy with the investors
of fungal growthing low hp units works
very well fungal growth and infesters
are still usable today but are far from
their initial dominance thanks in part
to nerfs to the ability as well as the
introduction of new units to counter
their ability
coming in at number eight is profits
tempest from call of duty black ops four
damn i could have three pieces
who are you oh
look black ops 4 had some truly busted
specialist abilities and in several
cases specialists were banned completely
from competitive play but one specialist
that made it through had a piece of
equipment that terrorized the
competition profit and the tempest bolt
action rifle well if we could do this
right
wait
wait
bang what it right out the weapon fired
electrified projectiles that knocked
enemies down allowing them to be picked
off with ease add to that the fact that
the electricity could arc to nearby
targets and it felt like a pretty unfair
piece of kit and players like dashi
became known for making the tempest into
a living nightmare for their opponents
through we'll be looking for that
hellstorm as well one more would do it
are you kidding
who does that
taking the number seven spot on our list
is the single most broken ability from
smash's most broken character meta
knight's mac tornado from brawl every
single part of meta knight's kit in
brawl was so broken he was the best
character in the game by a mile kirby's
dark rival had so much going for him and
all of his special moves had a place but
the cherry on top was mack tornado his
neutral b move that turned him into a
whirling force of destruction oh i just
got brawl wait we a fun game a fun new
game i just like you know games brand
new i've been playing for a week or i'm
not that good and then they run into
this move and they're like i quit bro
that one was funny mac tornado did it
all the things shredded shield gave him
another mobility option that he
definitely didn't need and actually did
a ton of damage sure the rest of meta
knight's kit was broken as well but mack
tornado would have been the best move in
the game on any other character but
instead they gave it to the best
character in the game and it was a
nightmare it's not biased we're just not
it's real it's real commentary yeah it's
jason
the number six entry on our list is
another glitched out dota ability that
really broke the game
the necro kills oh i feel so bad for my
control right now it looked like you're
just having a really good time it's
literally artesian fear against five in
the enemy base the other heroes didn't
even join and they're kiting for
suspects looks like it's business now
arc warden is not a dota 2 hero who
usually buys divine rapier a powerful
late game item that's dropped when its
owner dies that's because the weapon has
no effect on the clones created by the
hero's tempest double ability a specific
exception in the abilities description
and that exists because when the hero
came out the clones created by tempest
double were able to gain the benefits of
the rapier but did not drop it when they
died it's no surprise that this
interaction was changed and now if
you're an ark warden player there's no
need to agonize over that rapier
purchase
at the halfway point on alice might be
the only ability that was broken on
purpose younes zescho hoho from street
fighter 4 arcade edition when young came
out with super street fighter 4 arcade
edition players immediately complained
about the ex version of his zescho hoho
it was a nearly screenwide dash punch
that was completely safe on block as i'm
sure you guessed ex-punch itself is
fantastic for pressure since it puts you
point blank and plus even on block if
your initial pressure string didn't pan
out just ex-punch and try again
maybe it wasn't the only strong part of
the character but it was one of the
moves that seemed to frustrate people
the most and when the beast himself
diego decided to pick up yun instead of
his favored ryu it was pretty clear
something needed to be done
by evo 2011 capcom was apologizing for
the state of youn and promising fixes
which eventually nerfed the insane lunch
punch it was a big reversal from a
previous interview where capcom's
yoshinori ono talked about how arcade
edition was intentionally unbalanced
with young being broken on purpose but
all things are cyclical and eventually
capcom went right back to buffing this
stupid punch to help give him another
option to close it on the opponent
dion's ex lunge punch has been adjusted
so that is now slightly more
advantageous on block this means that
jun will be able to get in without being
punished as easily as before
taking the number 4 spot on our list is
blackbeard's shield from rainbow six
siege the reason why blackbeard is as
powerful as he is right now is that he
can basically claim an entire room by
himself with not really putting himself
at any disadvantage whatsoever in siege
a headshot from any gun at all is an
instant kill so players learn to go for
headshots pretty quickly but everyone
had to unlearn that habit when
blackbeard dropped in year one his
gadget was a rifle that attached to his
primary weapon and covered you guessed
it his head back then the shield had 800
health meaning when he turned the corner
and you went for the head you damaged
his shield and he killed you so when i'm
playing blackbeard what i'm trying to do
is hold down lines of sight use his
rifle shield to my advantage and i'm
basically asking people to peek me i'm
hoping that people will pick me because
of the rifle shield i have an advantage
and i should win that gun fight the way
the shield works now in siege is that it
has enough health to give you a split
seconds advantage you still lose gun
fights if you're too slow with a shield
in its current state it seems unlikely
to dominate the meta anytime soon but
back in its glory days it was broken
the first member of the top three club
is mercy's original res and for all you
og's out there here's a sound that
should trigger some nightmares
heroes never die if you played overwatch
in the early days you remember it a
mercy hiding behind a crate or in a side
path watching her teammates die on mass
all so she could dash in alt and undo an
entire team fight single-handedly
thank you mercy
mercy's original all resurrected all
dead teammates in range no line of sight
needed that meant all mercy needed to do
was stay safe and not fight until a huge
five-man rez was needed the problem was
pretty obvious if an enemy team popped
all their ults and cooldowns to kill
your team and then your mercy
resurrected them all then the enemies
had no way to fight back perez was
broken ultimately mercy's old was turned
into a mobility and healing output
increase and she was given a slow single
target rez that puts the medic in a
pretty dangerous spot during the cast
the runner-up spot on our list goes to
what might be league of legends oldest
broken ability twisted fate's original e
quizzler's e was gate yes the
teleporting ability that is now the
second activation of his alt used to be
on a basic ability it could be on an 18
second cooldown late in the game and not
to mention it was global level 1 if you
wanted to be troll you could take your e
and just hop into the enemy's fountain
just because so back in the league of
legends alpha twisted fate e gate let
him teleport anywhere onto the map with
a three second cast time if you don't
understand just how broken this is the
only way to teleport in league now is to
use certain champions alts or the
teleport summoner spell which takes
about four seconds to cast and has at
least a 240 second cooldown needless to
say quick easy teleporting was broken
twisted fate was the ultimate ganker he
could appear anywhere at any time and
even if he died he could return to lane
immediately after respawning with gate
lock a gold card in the fountain destiny
and then gate directly behind them
keep in mind your auto attack damage is
almost negligible so prioritize
positioning for your second gold card
over auto attack
assuming they lived through your initial
gold card wild card combo this ability
was eventually rolled into twisted fates
alt and while gate was an incredibly
busted ability it really compounded the
other advantages the character had as
well
all right here it is taking the number
one spot on our list is an ability so
broken it literally changed the way
siege was played and led to the first
competitive quarantine in the game's
history what makes lions so powerful
well a lot of people say just stay still
but that's not easy when you're getting
flashed or pushed or jackled or rushed
out by a shield yellow just stood still
just now and what happened lions ee 1d
drone essentially gave lions team war
hacks when used it highlighted enemies
that moved during its duration through
walls pretty nuts when a lot of walls
are destructible and since standing
still in rainbow six seed is about as
safe as trying to breathe salt water it
was an aggressive ability that locked
down the defenders well we were in
atlantic city in the pro league finals
and my monitor broke in warm up so we
were warming up i don't remember against
who it was but my job was to play lion
even though i hated him as much as i did
so the the admins came and took my
monitor off my table
and i still got two assists by just
pressing four on my keyboard without
having a monitor in an fps game because
i had a broken overpowered operator the
ability led to an era of siege where
attackers could choose to move quickly
and it also made re-takes pretty
difficult after lyon was effectively
banned from pro play he returned with
huge nurse and honestly good riddance
all right there those were some pretty
broken abilities i do know that there
are tons more out there though so please
let me know in the comments if you think
there's an ability that really should
have been on this list thanks for
watching guys and i'll see you all in
the next one
no no i'm i was just practicing
i just send it to you and it's just me
going like